gabriel colletis professeur agrégé de
sciences économiques à l'université de
toulouse 1 gabriel colletis merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors pour
commencer comment comprendre la démarche
des deux députés de la majorité
mais je pense que les deux députés de la
majorité
en fait tu exprimes autour un certain
nombre d'interrogations que de très
nombreux français ont concernant cette
cette réforme des retraites
ces deux députés posent des questions
qui sont des questions qui me semblait
extrêmement précises en matière de
compensation s'agissant à la fois du
travail de l'activité des retraites
futures de certaines professions
libérales
s'agissant des enseignants chercheurs ou
des enseignants en général
donc en fait on est il confronté je
dirais à deux grandes séries de
problèmes
un premier problème une première
question qui qui est globale comment
cette votre cette réforme est elle pensé
dans son financement global
et puis il ya une seconde catégorie des
questions qui concernent des professions
plus spécifiques comme les avocats les
enseignants chercheurs ou d'autres
d'autres professions donc ce que l'on
peut peut-être faire dans le débat c'est
peut-être ne pas tout de suite aller
vers des questions spécifiques mais tout
d'abord regardé l'équation globale et
après si vous voulez bien on ira vers
des questions plus peut-être avant on
peut noter un que ces deux députés sont
pas des moindres laurent saint martin
rapporteur de la commission des finances
est garant à ce titre de la
responsabilité budgétaire et puis
également emily carillon responsable du
groupe la république en marche
finalement est-ce qu'ils enfoncent pas
le clou après l'avis du conseil d'état
j'ai bien sûr il enfonce le clou mais il
enfonce le clou de manière particulière
c'est à dire qu'il n'en met pas en cause
l'architecturé globale de la réforme
mais ils s'inquiètent
des compensations budgétaire si vous
préférez du coût budgétaire que vont
avoir un certain nombre de mesures
concernant des professions particulière
on pense bien sûr aux avocats et comme
je le disais à l'instant et aux
professions libérales
on pense aux enseignants aux enseignants
chercheurs mais encore une fois il
s'agit de questions qui sont des
questions spécifiques ils ne remettent
pas en cause ses deux députés ne
remettra pas en cause globalement la
réforme de retraites le principe d'une
réforme à pointe par exemple
alors on a entendu l'appel à l'unité des
manuels macron comment est ce que vous
voyez cette démarche de ces deux gradés
de la république en marche
est ce qu'elles montrent un front désuni
sur ce dossier non je ne crois pas
qu'ils aient de front désuni je crois
qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'interrogations que les députés de
certains députés de la république en
marche
eh bien on est ne font que refléter les
interrogations que tous les tous les
français on est encore une fois s'il ya
bien des questions qui sont des
questions spécifiques à certaines
professions parce que on veut et bien
passé un régime qui est un régime
universel et supprimer toutes les
régions que les régimes spécifiques
il ya bien et quand même une
interrogation général que ces deux
députés ne porte pas sur le bien-fondé
de la retraite elle même dans son
intégralité
alors vous le disiez au coeur des
interrogations des deux élus les impacts
budgétaires des des différentes
une compensation pardonnez moi est-ce
que vous pouvez nous éclairer davantage
ou le flou persiste encore écoutez je
pense qu'il ya un certain flou sur la
loi sur les mesures générales
on ne sait pas exactement on a 100 sur
les mesures générales
quelle sera la base de calcul de la
valeur du point
et ça ça intéresse absolument tout le
monde le gouvernement nous dit qu'il
faut créer un indicateur qui serait le
revenu d'activité moyen par tête des
français à cet indicateur n'existe pas
donc indexés finalement la valeur du
point sur un indicateur qui n'existent
pas d'un site évidemment très très
inquiétant
de la même manière que ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est le flou général sur ce
qu'on a pu appeler l'âge pivot sur l'âge
au delà duquel les biens il faudra
partir effectivement en retraite
et là je voudrais juste rappeler une
chose c'est que dans la fourchette des
60 64 ans qui est très concerné bien
évidemment par les retraites
le taux d'activité en france est très
bas il est de l'ordre de 33% aussi ce
qui me paraît être le plus grand homme
en d'autres termes les gens risquent
d'arriver à la retraite à 65 ans 66 ans
avec de nombreuses années qu'ils leur
manquent pour avoir une retraite à taux
plein donc on a des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes à caractère général qui
concerne toutes les professions et puis
après on a évidemment des problèmes qui
sont des problèmes spécifiques à
certains régimes
je suis enseignant chercheur à
l'université vous savez bien que des
enseignants chercheurs ont démontré dans
la carrière qui est relativement retardé
en raison de la longueur des études
on peut considérer qu'un enseignant
chercheur entre aline a cité entre 28 et
30 ans s'il doit travailler pendant 43
ans et bien ça veut dire simplement il
va devoir travailler jusqu'à plus de 70
ans pour avoir une retraite à taux plein
par ailleurs on sait que les enseignants
chercheurs et les enseignants en général
en france ont des niveaux de salaires
qui sont plus faibles dans la moyenne de
ces lieux et c'est dans cette
perspective là que le gouvernement
envisage une revalorisation des salaires
n'est s'est trouvé là il descendit
salaires at elle concerner les seuls
jeunes enseignants qui ont
la profession ou bien tous les
enseignants là encore les choses sont
loin d'être fixé et on pourrait
continuer comme ça la liste très très
longuement en prenant le cas des avocats
ou de l'ensemble des professions
libérales qui je cherche à maintenir en
quelque sorte d'un système de retraite
parce que celui ci était bien équilibrée
il est bien gérée et ne veulent pas que
les réserves de leurs propres régimes
soient versés aux dents dans l'ensemble
du site
on voit bien qu'il ya deux catégories de
problèmes des problèmes généraux main
dans le cadre desquels il ya aussi les
problèmes de pénibilité qui ont été
évoqués dans votre reportage
et puis des problèmes spécifiques à
certaines professions
au total ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que le débat me semble être un débat
d'une grande complexité
hélas au risque de voter finalement les
parlementaires risquent de modèles dans
des conditions de grande urgence avec
éventuellement à la clé 1 49 3 je pense
que c'est pas du tout comme ça qu'il
faut et bien posé la question devant la
représentation nationale il faut prendre
tout le temps nécessaire pour aller au
bout d'une réforme et doit être
consensuelle
évidemment ce qu'elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui alors la commission sociale
retraites mises en échec
c'est tout de même à accorder sur une
règle d'or une trajectoire sur cinq ans
imposant l'équilibré du système
comment assurer l'équilibré sans
expliquer s'il y à l'augmentation des
salaires 6 à la baisse de la csg si
compensation justement cette notion d'
équilibre et une leçon qui est
extrêmement le contestable parce que
quelle peut être la nature de l'
équilibre dans cinq ans ceci dépendra
énormément de rythme de croissance
économique dépendra du taux d'activité
des seniors dépendra de toute une série
de paramètres du taux de chômage
évidemment qui aujourd'hui sont assez
mal connue donc posé une règle
d'équilibré statique où quelque sorte à
5 ans me paraît quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile
tu crois que si la question des
retraites n'est pas une icône qu'elles
sont comptables je pense que cette
question doit être posée en fonction de
ce que on comprend par activité de
travail activité salariée aujourd'hui on
se
on se prive avec des gens qui partent à
la retraite autrefois souvent d'ailleurs
au pré retraite et bien de gens qui
pourraient transmettre leurs compétences
transmettre leurs compétences aux jeunes
salariés vont plutôt que d'appréhender
uniquement la question des retraites
sous l'angle du financement aussi un
angle comptable ce que je peux
comprendre
il faudrait qu'il y ait une réflexion
plus générale en france sur la question
des retraites sur la question du travail
sur les relations entre les travailleurs
les plus expérimentés et ceux qui
accèdent à l'entreprise c'est toute
cette problématique là qui est
évidemment problématique très riche une
problématique de société
il devrait être posée alors que là on en
train de s'enfermer dans un débat de
chiffres le compensation budgétaire
immédiate est évidemment nécessaire mais
qui est très loin d'être suppléé
justement c'est ce qui permettrait
peut-être du coup de sortir du flou dans
lequel nous sommes tous parce que
finalement il ya des modes de calcul qui
semble traduire parfois l'amateurisme
non une forme d'amateurisme il ya une
forme de de précipitations je pense que
le conseil d'état quelque part 10 pouces
le conseil d'état dit arrêtons proposons
de l'opposant nous tranquillement autour
de la table des bâtons c'est un sujet de
société extrêmement important qui
engagera l'avenir des français sur
plusieurs décennies
et là on recherche aller très très vite
à faire passer une réforme dans des
conditions qui sont ne sont pas de
bonnes conditions de discussion je crois
que l'attitude la plus sage serait comme
certaines fois sociales en plus de
suggérer est bien de dire du bien
en effet on entend de l'avis du conseil
d'état on entend les réserves qui sont
exprimés y compris au sein de la
majorité
et puis on prend le temps de réfléchir
de manière plus large et pas simplement
du point de vue comptable
alors pour terminer on le disait la
conférence de financement débutera la
semaine prochaine
comment trouver 12 milliards d'euros
voire même plus sans retarder l'âge de
départ
je crois que c'est une question qui est
en effet extrêmement difficile mais on
sait aussi que que les régimes de
retraite ont des réserves qui sont des
réserves extrêmement importante donc
le problème n'est pas véritablement me
trouver ou de ne pas trouver les deux
médias c'est d'avoir une conception
générale du travail en france
avoir une conception générale de la
solidarité entre les personnes qui
travaillent et des systèmes des
personnes qui ont travaillé autrefois
donc un régime qui est en effet le
régime de solidarité
intergénérationnelle est ce que l'on
peut regretter avec la retraite à points
c'est qu'il individualise
considérablement la question des
retraites
il est dit aujourd'hui que les cadres
qui gagneront plus de trois fois le
salaire minimum est bien seront libres
de cotiser autrement et donc pourront
éventuellement affecter des sommes
qu'ils prévoient pour leur retraite à
des systèmes d'assurance privée qui
évidemment sont très loin les éloigner
des logiques de solidarité alors
peut-être certains de ce fait je ne sais
pas si tu un débat on voit bien que la
quantité de débat la complexité des
débats est très grande et donc il faut
prendre le temps nécessaire et c'est ce
que je pense
veux le dire certains membres de la
majorité actuellement
merci beaucoup gabriel colletis d'avoir
partagé votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur agrégé de sciences
économiques à l'université de toulouse 1